That incredibly talented young boy with soon a talented young man composing
symphonies can cello. Hello? Hello, Robert. Hi. Hi. Let me, well,
what was that? That was, that was a, the mist of classical music, public radio,
basically interrupted by science journalist and author David [inaudible]. Hey,
are we all here now? Now we're all here. And you are [inaudible].
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab. Yeah. Yeah.
And actually what happened here is I called David because he has just published
a book which contains an idea that I found so surprising.
I had not known of this. It's kind of a,
a smack in the face to Charles Darwin's theory of evolution. Yes.
There have been a number of excellent at Gu that have been added to Darwin's
theory over the last 150 years or so since he published it.
But this is, this is more than that. This is a big fricking asterisk.
And to explain what that means, David told me a story about a month.
Yes, the pepper lock. It lives
in forest of central England among other places.
And during the 19th century,
this moth was white with little flecks of black on it and these moths,
sometimes Ruth's done the on the trunks of trees and the trunks of trees
surrounding Manchester, England were sort of light colored.
So when these moths roosted on the trees,
they were pretty well camouflaged a light, slightly peppered moth.
Lana light slightly peppered the tree trunk.
So they were protected against predation by birds. And then
the tree trunks changed. Why did the tree trunks chain,
okay,
because of the industrial revolution,
because of the smokestacks of Manchester,
we're turning out a lot of cold smoke.
They were burning coal for all their industrial processes and there was this
set, this cold sweat that was coming out and it was blanketing the trees in the
nearby forest. So the tree trunks turned black
and the moths were no longer camouflage cause the Mazda were white.
You wouldn't want to be a white moth sitting against the coal black tree because
then you or your herd would know exactly where you are.
Right.
What happened? The moths turned black.
Oh yes, sure. This is the, this is the classic sort of evolution story. Exactly.
That story was told, it was a,
became a textbook example of Darwinian evolutionary change in,
in real time. And the way that happens,
we were told is that once the trees turn dark,
the moths changed by incremental mutation. Like, you know, uh,
thanks to some tiny little mistake in some moth gene,
the black spackling got bigger,
uncertain moths and those were a little bit more protected.
And then the spackling got a little bit bigger.
The morals got a little grayer and then very,
very slowly over generation after generation, after generation of mouth,
they get a little bit darker and then darker still till you end up eventually
with a population of Martha turns completely black.
That's the classic story, except,
except that we now know that's wrong. It turns out it wasn't slow.
It didn't take generations and generations.
The sequencing of the moth genome has revealed a stretch of DNA,
22,000 letters of the DNA code that suddenly jumped into these moths from
somewhere and in a flash,
the moths changed from white to black pretty much in one day.
Really a white peppered moth mom,
all of a sudden producer's an all black baby. Wait,
so how did that, how did that happen?
They said a whole packet of jeans just got shoved in to this new from where did
it come from? Well,
David says it probably jumped one part of the moth genome to a completely new
part. Different part. But what that means of course, is that living things,
it turns out can change way faster than we thought.
And therefore evolution can happen much faster than we thought.
And on top of that, David says,
scientists have now discovered is even stranger kind of super fast change that
takes things will be about parents and offspring, individuals, species,
things we've counted on for years and just throws the whole mix into the air.
Yes, infective heredity, infective heredity.
What is, what is that hardly enough to explain this to you? I have to go back.
Hello,
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab or talk to an earlier version
of us because it was 11 years ago,
I think that we made a show called a so called life life. Not as we knew it.
Oh God, that's true.
And in that show we dealt with an early sort of more primitive version of this
very question. So I'm just gonna play you a few minutes of that,
of that earlier show. Well, let's talk about life. You and I,
and we'll come right back.
When you look around in the world at living things and I say, Look Dad,
there's a cat next that is a dog and that's a tree.
And you noticed that those things of course are different. Yes.
And later when we go to school we learn about phylums and categories like
kingdoms and stuff.
So you think about the nature of those differences and then you're taught about
struggle and competition. Darwin species.
There is a new theory that's being talked about that turns all of that on its
head. I heard it first from this guy. I'm Steve Strogatz.
I'm an applied mathematician at Cornell and the story he told me,
which is based on analysis of DNA in very tiny organisms, microbes,
is that once upon a time he says, life began with a very primitive,
very simple collection of cells and these cells
[inaudible]
these cells. It appears that as you, when you go back
far enough, there is a kind of rampant sharing of molecules.
It's a kind of orgy in which there are no well-defined species or organisms and
I can give you my genes and you can pass. We're a colony
[inaudible]
I totally remember recording that.
The Kumbaya thing that certain wheeler who was there at the start,
he produced this piece years ago. Yes. I think it was just us around the office.
How many? Yeah, it was a commune. What? What does that mean? He's like,
it was a commune. What do you mean? What is it meaning?
I know what it means in the 60 screen. Love sense, but what does it really mean?
What? Oh, what cells are exchanging is chemicals,
chemicals that give them talents and traits. Genes. Here's what happens.
I did this with [inaudible]
in our, in our ancient puddle,
we in Darwin thought that life might have begun in a warm hello.
Let's say that you and I are both cells. Okay?
So once upon a time there was you and a puddle and I'm in the same puddle as you
and it gets a little colder in the puddle. So we should all get sick,
but you don't get sick. You have some kind of accidental talent.
You can handle cold water. I'm shivering.
Describe again what happens in at this point, in the glorious old days,
my membrane that is I, I'm a cell, I've got a membrane, I've got my outer layer,
maybe a little bit porous and maybe, whoops, I'm on my jeans just leaked out.
Okay? We're not talking sophisticated organisms and maybe your poorest too.
And Oh wow. You just absorbed some of those genes. So now we both have this,
we both got and you both go.
And if I've got this gene now I can survive cold water because it's part of me.
And if I bump into you now it's part of you.
So now this Steve Jean has become a Robert Keane,
which has then become a Jag gene and we're doing it over and over and over and
we're getting really, um, come here.
[inaudible]
it sounds so friendly. I actually don't think of,
sounds like people shout out all these exchanges.
This gene swapping was not intentional. It's not purposeful sharing.
That's Nigel golden fell MSC medical physicist at the University of Illinois and
he and his colleague Carl woes did the science that led to some of these kind of
goofy ideas, not me sort of saying, hey,
I'm going to just help out my buddy over that.
Here's a couple of genes and I think you'll find handy.
It's not something like that. You can still,
if we're swamping jeans so much and you know,
you're giving me yours and I'm going to be nine. Yeah.
What does it actually mean to be me? Yeah.
So much of me is spread around. Well, it would be very weird.
Imagine a world in which for a while I have your nose, God forbid,
and then I get my nose back. You'd have Steve's hair.
Then Steve would get my ear. Then he would get your nose.
Once you still having a lot of exchange, I'll take your chin. Okay?
And you can have my allergies and then you start even asking what does it mean,
um, to be a speech. You can have my love affair with doubt.
You may not even be able to talk about individuals.
Yeah. If the mixing is good enough, we're all kind of indistinguishable.
So identity would be very strange in this ancient world when all of the concepts
that we take for granted in it
biology become more and more nebulous as you get further and further back to the
root of the origin of life. Take for instance Charles Darwin.
What Nigel was really saying is that for the first billion years of life with
the beat you to be everything that Darwin teaches,
all that stuff hasn't happened to no borders, no individuals has no species.
That is Darwinism evolution as we now understand it. That's an interlude
[inaudible]
and the real story of life. It's only what's happening now.
What you got back at the very beginning was a whole bunch of cells slopping
genes, swapping advantages, swapping disadvantages,
and this kind of goes wild time.
What tremendous explosion of diversity in a way that life has not seen since
then.
[inaudible]
until
one dark and terrible day 3 billion years ago,
as interpreted by Freeman Dyson, famous physicist and delivered here.
Now our friend, the mathematician Steve Strug as heres d one evil day,
a bacterium anticipating Bill Gates by 3 billion years.
Refuse to share.
[inaudible]
refuse to share. Ooh,
the first bad guy is this cellular bill k two who decides that I've,
I've got an innovation that I don't feel like sharing or possibly by found a way
to keep my membrane from leaking. That is,
I'm not going to be a sharing soul anymore. And why?
I mean what made that one little cell decide to stop sharing?
That's a good question. We don't really know,
but what we do know this is was maybe the most dramatic moment in the history of
life on earth.
This transition from the age of, well,
if you want to call it the age of sharing to the age of selfishness and
gradually once one creatures stopped sharing,
pretty soon the others followed and then more and more did the same thing.
And now for the first time in the history of life, finally we get Darwin.
Now we get species. Now we see differences. Yes,
it's the age of identity of individualism. It's also the age of, of Stacey.
Things change, but they change much more slowly in any great thing. You know,
like you are a bat and you've figured out sonar. I, I don't have sonar.
I can't get sonar. I mean, I used to have sonar,
like you're at a little electric fish that lives in the muddy waters of the
Amazon. You don't care. It's totally dark. You can see,
because you can see with electricity, I can't see with electricity.
If I'm in the dark, I'm bumping my head.
[inaudible]
did we really use Bill Gates as a stand in for like selfishness? Yeah. Well,
I mean,
at the time he was the ultimate corporate horrible that we did that [inaudible]
faith foundation. That's right. He's actually gone over to the,
to the light side instead of the dark side. Yeah, right, exactly.
That is a Steve Strogatz.
I ended up calling him up just to chat them through some of this stuff and he
told me that he actually heard this whole idea from a lecture by physicist
Freeman Dyson. Dyson is just a great writer and a great speaker.
And he had this memorable line in there,
at least memorable to me when he started talking about,
I mean he phrased the whole thing in terms of sharing,
which may be why in that previous episode we had that Kumbaya us saying games.
That wasn't my doing by the way. No, no, that was, that was us. But anyway,
so then he said, but one evil day,
some primitive bacterium anticipating bill gates by 3 billion years,
refuse to share its DNA. And then, oh, so that was, that was Freeman Dyson.
Yeah, that was his joke. So anyway, it was,
I was sitting there in this lecture and he started mentioning a certain
biologist, Carl woes,
and he talked about him in such glowing terms as one of the great
microbiologists of our time. And I'm so you,
so you hadn't heard of Carl woes I had before? No, I had not. So I,
the reason I was asking the show,
we actually mentioned cro was because I remember it, you know,
I don't know if you guys know there's not, but so that was 11 years ago, right?
I was actually an intern at the time.
I had just showed up and I was tasked with tracking down Carl woes.
Who's the guy that we mentioned?
I sort of like the grandfather of this idea and he was like, oh, huge,
huge deal in science. Um,
he discovered this whole other branch on the tree of life, the archaic. Oh,
he's Mr RKM, which was a pretty big one. It's a whole nother,
whole nother kingdom of, yeah.
It got 'em on the front page of the New York Times and I had to track him down
and it turns out he was like the,
just the classic curmudgeonly scientists.
It took me 20 emails to get him to even like just let us talk to his
collaborator, Nigel Goldenfeld who we talked to in the show, but whatever.
It is a very strange, he was a very curmudgeonly man, but you know,
like he came to like me and I actually spent some time with him,
his office and we, I can do the curmudgeonly thing if I need to, you know,
we share some
get skills. Yeah. I could, we pass some curmudgeonly jokes back and forth.
And um, anyway, uh, after he heard the piece,
he wrote me the most seizing scathing email about and nothing,
there was nothing in it about like, you got this wrong. It was just like,
you made a cartoon of my work, which honestly now listening back,
I agree with a little more than I did at the time. Yeah, yeah. But he was like,
I'm a serious person. And you've made this into like a dog and pony show.
And I was like, I was brand new. I was, and it hurt. I mean like I was,
I felt really, really bad and he's like, you've disrespected Nigel.
And so I wrote, I wrote to I or called up Steve Maybe and said, Oh man,
you know, this happened. And Steve was like, Hey, listen, forget them.
Don't worry about it. Oh, I love Steve. Yeah. I don't know. I, I,
it sounds like something I might've said to you. Do you remember having that?
I don't remember.
I honestly don't remember having that conversation and that was like, oh,
I needed that so bad at that moment.
My career for someone like with Steve Stature to like balance it out in that
way. Yeah. Um, yeah, I think, I mean, it's a little bit funny that he would,
to me a little surprising that he wouldn't have gotten what you were trying to
do or what we were trying to do.
I think our playfulness in an attempt to be clear and to communicate and to
attract people who might not otherwise listen to a story about something called
horizontal gene transfer.
He should have gotten that because he himself in his writing was very playful.
He was very fun to talk to. I mean, he was absolutely, Carl was,
was very playful and irascible and grouchy and charming,
but he would certainly tell you what he thought. Yeah, yeah. This,
this guy has a great character and David Quam, and it turns out in his new book,
talks a lot, a lot,
a lot about Carl woes and this revolution in our thinking,
talking about the evolution of life or the end of his life.
He started to think that he was more important and more profound than Darwin.
He got a very negative attitude toward, toward Charles Darwin Darwin's birthday.
He'd said that he sent out a note to everybody here that this should be a day of
rage. That's right. Yes. Yes. He did that,
but I guess I'm wondering is now that you spent a book's attention on him,
do you feel that he has some right to say that the picture we have of how life
changes needs serious amending or is he just barking because he's a barker?
No, he, um,
he was entitled not to think that he was greater than Darwin,
but to think that what he discovered was very,
very damn important to understanding the full history of evolution on earth.
What has happened all throughout the history of life on the planet 4 billion
years and is still happening today.
This is where we are now.
The crazy details coming up right after the break.
[inaudible]
this is young Juetten calling from a story in New York.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, it's Chad.
I boom rod this season and more perfect from Debbie NYC studios might be the
most perfect yet 19th amendment women have been fighting for the legal right to
vote. Says the 1840s
this season we are making an album featuring, for example,
Dali part an album of songs and stories inspired by the amendments to the u s
constitution. Listen to more
perfect wherever you get your podcasts.
Jad Robert Radiolab,
and we're back with David Coleman and this new new to us way of changing life,
infective heredity, these leaping genes,
these transfers of DNA that create new genetic possibilities in a blink.
Turns out,
David told us that the swapping of genes that we talked about in the early
history of life, that's still happening today, correct? Yes.
Bacteria all around us. Those bugs are trading genes.
Genes are jumping sideways from one kind of bacteria to another,
even in our belly is even in our guts.
So let's say that you go to ranch on a vacation and you touch something there
and then you lick your finger. I don't know. I couldn't, you know, or oh,
you eat something,
not new bacteria from that European food is going to enter your stomach.
And now, not only do you have some new bugs in you,
but they can start trading their genes with bugs that are already in you. Yes.
What would that mean? Like physically?
Like would it look like boop out the cell wall?
And then they found that there were several different mechanisms for this.
Two bacteria would create a little pipe, a little sort of penis,
like thing between them and genes would be transferred,
but jeans were moving sideways under other circumstances too,
from dead busted open bacteria into live bacteria is it acquire this new trait
at once, immediately, immediately in an instant, a new population,
even in new species of bacteria can possess all of those.
Gradually laboriously acquired adaptations that, um,
another strain of bacteria evolve these bugs.
They don't have to wait around for generation after generation to pick up random
mutation.
Our bacteria inside us can pick up whole new abilities and new tricks all at
once from their new neighbors. So for instance,
one kind of bacteria could pass genes for antibiotic resistance to another
completely different kind of bacteria.
So say you've got somebody sitting in a hospital with a staphylococcus
infection,
some of the bugs inside have figured out how to resist penicillin.
When that bug then comes out of that human and it gets left on a table in a
hospital and somebody else gets infected by it,
then they will also have an infection that is resistant to penicillin.
But if say they happen to be in the hospital,
sick with something totally different,
they have a different kind of harmful bacteria doing trouble giving them
trouble,
then those old bacteria in them can learn in a flash from the new bacteria.
Now everybody's penicillin resistant and that's why the,
that's why antibiotic resistance is spreading around the world.
So lickety split that is really important. That's a,
that's a global health crisis in the World Health Organization among others have
called that a global health crisis.
Tens and tens and tens of thousands of people are dying from that.
So that's really important and urgent.
But the most important part of this whole subject is not practical.
It's a matter of understanding, understanding the history of life,
understanding who we are, quite literally, because according to David,
the way we are, we humans are,
has been affected by visits from other creatures. Genes. Yes,
8% of the human genome is viral DNA.
80% of the DNA has come into humans or into our mammal ancestors sideways.
But here's how that goes.
Like you're sitting around and a virus gets into your bloodstream and it travels
into one of yourselves, and when it's in there,
it drops some of its DNA into your DNA.
And if it gets into an ovary, cellar,
sperm cell will then it will be passed along. So we,
8% of our genome has come to us that way from these viruses.
Some of that is just gobbledygook in our genome,
and some of it is instructions. In other words,
genes that are still performing functions.
And one of those creates a boundary layer between the human placenta and the
fetus. An absolutely necessary essential boundary layer.
Now this is came at a total shock to me because after all,
the thing that's really special about mammals is that female mammals, uh,
or at least placental mammals, um,
carry young around inside the body and the history of life.
This was a completely new development. I mean, you think about fish,
you think about reptiles, like the dinosaurs, you're thinking about the birds,
what are they doing? They have kids, they lay eggs.
But now we get a creature that comes along and figures out how to keep the baby
growing inside it. Of course, if it does that,
it has to make sure that it's immune system doesn't attack that baby and the
baby has to be able to poop and stuff like that and get things out.
So there has to be some kind of boundary.
And how did we get that good idea when we got that good idea from a virus long,
long ago, some ancient mammal ancestor got a virus,
got infected by a virus and that virus introduced a new gene,
the original virus. It created an envelope or wrapping around the virus,
but it has been adapted to create a different kind of wrapping,
the wrapping that goes around the fetus and inside the placenta so it carries
nutrients in.
It protects the fetus from the mother's immune system and it is allowing waste
products from the fetus to be carried away and disposed of by the mother.
I mean to assist potentially the origin of mammals and within this being the
without, which if we hadn't gotten this talent from viruses,
we wouldn't have gotten the kinds of mammals that we have now that that layer
could not exist and does not function without this viral gene telling it what to
do without this little bit of of virus DNA,
you can't be a mammal, you can't be a mother mammo and you can't be a child.
In light of this stuff, and for me,
in light of five years of studying it and following it and interviewing people
about it,
the categories that we apply to the world categories like individual and species
now appear more blurry. The edges are fuzzy.
Is there such a thing as a human individual or is it a human,
a composite of other forms of life.
And what this says is that we are composites. We are mosaics.
Whoa.
It's humbling and it's,
and it's fascinating to think of yourself that way. Like for me,
David.
So it turns out that David is not just the descendant of a Norwegian father and
a German Irish mother,
but he's also viral and bacterial and who knows what else.
And I find that, um, I find that thrilling.
[inaudible]
uh, I'm,
I'm grateful to all those other limbs on the tree of life for the things that
they've given us.
[inaudible]
thanks of course to Steven Strogatz of Cornell University, um,
who is always willing to jump back into the ponds where he longed since I'd left
and thought he'd gotten dried off from David Commons.
New Book is called the tangled tree and it's a gorgeous book.
So thanks to them and thanks to all of you for listening and Jab. I'm Ron.
I'm Robert Krulwich. We'll see you next time.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
wait a second. Is that Kumbaya the slide?
Or you snuck it in one second. Trojan.
My name is Debbie more than leukemia, calling from Mexico City.
Radiolab was created but Eben Rudd and it's produced by Soren Wheeler dealing
Keefe is our director of sound design.
Maria Metta [inaudible] is our managing director.
Our staff includes Simon Adler, that Guy Bressler, Rachel Cosick,
David [inaudible], Bethel Hafter, Tracy hunt, Matte Kielty,
Robert Krulwich, Annie Mcewen, Latif, Nasser, Melissa O'Donnell,
Arion Wack, Pat Walters, and Molly Webster with help from Shima. Oli, I. E.
Our fact checker is Michelle Harris.